hey how's it going i'm lily singh and
you're watching the wired autocomplete
interview
oh yeah
[Music]
what if i hit the camera and it fell
thank you all right when is lily sings
birthday oh easy
september 26th yes i will take gifts uh
who
is lilly singh replacing on nbc
i am replacing carson daly a lot of
people have thought it's jimmy fallon
or seth meyers or james corden it's none
of those white men it is the other white
man
carson daly who has been very sweet and
supportive i need to say
lily sing who wants to be a millionaire
ah i know what this is the highlight of
my life
was being a question on who wants to be
a millionaire it was something along the
lines of
who is a really sexy youtuber that's
very talented
i'm paraphrasing um and the answer was
me
what is lily sings favorite color
okay this is the whole thing because i
like pink
yellow makes me very happy but i feel
like i get judged for liking pink
because it's
it's supposed to be girly and then i'm
also conflicted because i don't want to
hurt any of the other colors feelings
this question stresses me out what is
lily sings what is lisa's real name
lisa's real name is lily singh
i know what you're thinking it's too
short for an indian person and you're
racist
okay it's just lily sing it's not indir
binder
jeet nothing just lily sing is what it
is
what does lee sings tattoo say oh i have
five
one is his heart and then i have
this says without fear so without hate
on my angle i don't put lotion on but
you can't see it there's a staircase
that's on every chapter of my book this
essentially just means like keep
climbing
keep working stay grounded um and then i
have just
taken the clothes off right here says
one love can you see it
it says one love which is my favorite
bob marley song and my general mantra
for life
what movies has lily sing
been in i've made small cameos and ice
age collision course
in bad moms and in fahrenheit 451 more
to come
hopefully casting directors what
lily singh character are you a lot of my
house is filled with beards and wigs
that's why i'm single i do a lot of
characters i dress up as my mom
and my dad then there's jessica then
there's samuel then there's linder
and there's a little lily and there's a
buzzfeed quiz about which character are
you i think i got
i think shockingly i didn't get myself i
think i might have gotten my mom
it's true what they say you just turn
into your parents this is a whole
someone make an appointment with my
therapist what is lilly singh's phone
number
okay okay i mean depends we'll see
why is lily's
why is lily saying that so
because i don't know why is lily's i
don't know i just have my in 1988
two immigrants from india came to canada
it was a drunken night
things happened they probably know how
to do it because they've been suppressed
their entire lives because such as
indian culture and then i came into
existence that that is why lilly's sick
why is lilly's thing called superwoman
ah great question so i
named myself superwoman in 2010 when i
created my youtube channel
clearly thinking it wouldn't go anywhere
because calling yourself a trademark dc
name
is not the smartest business move but it
just felt really empowering to me
it was based off a hip-hop song by
little mo and fabulous but i recently
dropped that and i go by lily now which
is my
fake name why is lily sing a hero
i mean you tell me i guess we're all our
own superheroes
i think i'm a superhero because if i had
to pick one thing
i think i'm a pretty great work ethic i
think that makes me a superhero why is
listening so popular
beats me i think i started making
youtube videos at a time when
no one else that looked like me did and
i was talking about things that no one
else was for my community
and i think a lot of people could relate
to that also i have great hair
and so even if i'm not funny people
don't really mind
is lily singh married to the rock no i'm
not married to the rock
uh not in this lifetime at least but he
has been
a great mentor to me i he was my idol
growing up absolutely obsessed i had the
opportunity to meet him
i'm grateful enough to say that we're
friends now and he gives me advice
during my most trying times is lacing
back on youtube
this makes me sad did i leave youtube i
did take a break from social media
the end of last year and i guess i don't
have as regimented as a schedule so
people might think i've left youtube but
i've not left youtube
i'm very passionate about the community
even with my new late night show
it's important to me to continue
uploading whenever i can on youtube
because i
love that community and that fan base so
so much is listening vegetarian i
am i am vegetarian not to be confused
with vegan i respect vegans but i feel
like not enough people know the
difference
between vegans and vegetarians so i
don't eat meat
but um cheese and stuff i still do
because
i like happiness is listing in f the
prom
oh yeah i
am in f the prom this was um produced by
the fine bros
they graciously asked me to cameo as a
teacher in this movie it is on netflix
so i guess my previous question of which
movies you're in i'm an idiot and i
forgot this one
is listing in stranger things what
oh okay i understand why you'd be
confused between me and the demigod
queen
we look very similar i look as similar
as that flower monster thing
but i'm not in stranger things i think
the reason this is here is because
i'm good friends with noah who is the
little boy that gets abducted into the
upside down i guess i i also have
chilled with millie a lot so maybe i
have a lot of friends in stranger things
and by association you think that
but no i'm not cool enough to be in
stranger things
is listening related to humble the poet
i know this is very confusing
because he has a turban and a beard and
he's also brown we're not related we're
just friends
also important note that every person
you see with the bearded turban
is not humble they're different people
just all wearing a turban
does lily sing have a sister i do i have
an older sister her name is tina
she's six years older than me just three
adorable baby boys who are my nephews
i followed her footsteps when i got my
psychology degree years later she
followed my footsteps to be on youtube
so
full circle moment where did leasing
come from
i am originally from toronto which is in
ontario
which is in canada um i guess that's
what that question means
for some reason my first instinct was to
say an egg
like yoshi i don't know why but that's
not where i came from
where does lily sing live i currently
live in la
in hollywood and i moved there in 2015.
but most the time i live in unicorn
island
does lising speak french do i
just yes i do speak french i'm from
canada
i learned french all the way up until
grade 10
and thus i know how to solely order a
pizza and nothing else
i don't know how to ask for help i don't
know how to say
uh i'm hurt i don't know how to ask for
directions
but i can order a pizza and also i know
circus terms
where did lilly sing go to college so i
actually went to university
and before you comment below saying
you're so pretentious why are you making
this correction
in canada it's different college and
university is different i went to york
university in north york
um and i was part of the dance team
there and our chant was deep in the
heart of york you jungle you can hear
the lions rumble
why uyu we never won a competition how
tall
is lily sing in feet i'm five foot five
inches
is that i think so on a good day five
foot five inches
i'm really lying i'm really short but i
keep saying five foot five like
on dating apps i always put five foot
five but whatever inside no one's gonna
know
is this going public how old is leasing
now
[Music]
i'm 25 26 i'm 30.
uh how many subscribers does lising have
on my main channel i am grateful to say
i have about 15 million subscribers
and on my second channel i believe i
have around 3 million so across both
channels it would be
18 million subtracting all the fake
accounts that are just me
5 million we're self-aware
listening how to be a boss pdf oh how to
be a boss is the book
i launched uh published i was like two
three-ish years ago
i'm grateful to say it was a new york
times bestseller it is a guide on how
not to
survive life but conquer life and it's
one of my greatest accomplishments
because yo it's like really hard to
write a book can we just take a moment
it's very hard i wrote i wrote every
word from me it took a year from my
birthday to my birthday because i'd like
to torture myself
i wrote this book it's 50 chapters and
i'm very very proud of it and like i
said it's not about just surviving life
it's about conquering so one of the
chapters is about don't just pay your
bills save enough to go on vacation
some of my favorite excerpts from the
book are embedded into the intro of my
late night show and that fast text
that's scrolling through
um so if you want to pause and find
those easter eggs if you care then
that's a thing that's cool that's an
exclusive for the wired that's an
exclusive no one else knows that
got you let's see how to make a sandwich
this is one of my favorite videos i made
a video a while ago when i first moved
to la called how to make a sandwich
and it was inspired by the good amount
of sexist comments i've gotten over my
youtube
career that would say women aren't funny
go back to the kitchen make a sandwich
as we know this is a very common thing
that i said to women
so i made an actual tutorial on how to
make a sandwich because so many people
didn't know how to make one
but it's a very sassy video where i'm
basically roasting the person
i left the comment one love we love
everyone but you know
light-hearted fun never hurt nobody
i learned a lot today i learned that no
matter how many thousands of videos i
have on the internet
people still don't know my real name
it's in my intro
and then i say it and then i say with my
outro i think people might not know
things about me
that's all